welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Deborah Brautigan a leading expert on
China in Africa and the Bernard L
Schwartz professor of international
political economy at Johns Hopkins
University her teaching and research
focus on international development
strategies governance and foreign aid
and she regularly advises international
agencies and governments on China Africa
economic engagement professor Brautigan
is the author of the dragon's gift the
real story of China in Africa and
Chinese aid and African Development
exporting Green Revolution she is with
us today because she is giving the
annual coca-cola world fund at Yale
lecture at the Macmillan Center and we
are delighted to be able to talk with
her about her new book will Africa feed
China
welcome professor of rottingham thanks
Maryland it's great to be here so let's
begin with the book tell us about it
the book is called will Africa feed
China and it examines the conventional
wisdom on what we think that Chinese are
doing in Africa with regard to
agricultural engagement and I think that
conventional wisdom really has four
points people think that the Chinese
have acquired a large amount of land
they think that the Chinese government
is leading this effort they think that
the purpose is to grow food to send back
to China and they think that they're
sending a lot of Chinese farmers to do
that ok so what led you to write the
book
well my first book was actually about
Chinese agricultural engagement in
Africa that was one about Chinese aid
and African development so I wrote that
book in the 1990s and I've been
following what the Chinese are doing for
a long time and it seemed to me that we
were really getting a lot wrong on what
they were doing and really
misunderstanding it and I kept seeing
these headlines about what they were
doing and I kept saying to myself this
isn't accurate and so I decided to dig
into this more deeply I had looked
the issue of agriculture in the Dragons
gift I had a couple of chapters on that
but it was really it really needed a
whole book to itself okay so it was
fascinating to actually discover what
the Chinese we're doing in Africa and
how little resemblance that bore to what
we thought they were doing interesting
interesting
so the the Chinese have been in Africa
for four decades then at this point
mm-hmm okay so how did you do the
methodology what was the research that
you did to write the book well I really
had a head start because I first went to
Africa to look at what the Chinese were
doing in the rural areas in 1983 so I
already had a lot of experience and I
knew a lot of cases of their foreign aid
and I also knew that over the years many
of those foreign aid projects had turned
into investments because they were often
done as state farms for African
governments so for this book we I worked
with a team of people I worked with
students and colleagues who were also
doing field work and we basically did
three things first of all we did what I
call internet investigative sleuthy and
so this is a kind of forensic internet
investigation where I and my students
dig into cases online to try to find out
what we can about them and the second
was we did fieldwork so we visited as
many cases as we could of investments
that it actually happened or those that
had failed and then tried to find out
what had happened and third we looked
very carefully at the Chinese government
incentive structure what were the
policies how did they go about trying to
encourage investment and what could we
find out from that okay so what are some
of the myths about China's agricultural
interest in Africa what are some of the
big ones well let's take for example the
idea that the Chinese have acquired
large amounts of farmland in Africa if
the Chinese had actually acquired all of
the farmland that people believe they
have out of all of the media stories and
all of the examples that are out there
it would be about six million hectares
and this is huge it's about 1% of all of
the arable land in Africa so it's quite
quite a lot of land and we found by
looking into sixty cases which we had
collected for
all different sources and trying to find
out what actually happened in each of
those that the amount of land that's
been transferred to Chinese companies is
240 around 240 thousand hectares which
is about twice the size of New York City
so it's a lot less land than people
think right do you have any idea as to
why these myths come about this one in
particular I think the idea that Africa
might be feeding China this is not
something that people that really know
Africa probably believe because Africa
is a big food deficit region every year
for example they're importing about 10
million tons of rice so that's an
enormous amount five to six billion
dollars they by and large most countries
our food deficit and so the idea that
they would be feeding China when they
can't feed themselves is very
unrealistic however I do think people
that don't know that might look at the
amount of land that people have in China
very little the amount of people they
have there very many and then Africa
seems to be a vast area with a lot of
land and so it seems like a natural that
the Chinese would want to grow their
food there right so they're just
basically making up stories that are not
true well they're doing things like
they're looking at a Chinese company
comes and they inquire about getting
some land I'll give you one example in
Zambia there was a real project at least
they wanted it to be a project a Chinese
company came they asked about doing a
very large project that would have been
biofuels and then this was reported as
though the Chinese government had come
and had asked for land to grow food to
send back to China and the whole idea of
this project was going to be to grow
biofuels which could be turned into fuel
and that they would sell this to the
Zambians because the Zambia was putting
in a requirement that they have a
certain percentage of ethanol in their
fuel and so this company thought they
could supply that so it was a the
intention the company wanted and and the
way it was spun when it got into the
media were entirely different
interesting so tell us about some some
other myths
well another myth is a Africa is
actually exporting food to China already
we looked at the trade
in order to figure this one out and what
we found is that there are a lot of
agricultural exports coming from Africa
but by and large it's things like
tobacco it's cotton it's things that are
going into industrial production like
rubber
there is one food commodity that's in
the top five
and that's sesame seeds so I don't think
that one could say that Chinese have a
voracious appetite for african sesame
they're trying to lock that up so that
they can feed themselves with it but
sesame is a very competitive crop in
Africa and the Chinese have come there
to buy it so they're buying it from
African farmers and again you know I am
curious how these myths happen and it's
just basically reporting that's not
quite accurate yes is that what it
amounts to I mean I think we developed a
preconceived idea that this would be
what the Chinese would want to do even
though they hadn't said they would want
to do that they were not sending
companies to do it the main examples of
industrial interests that we found were
in things like rubber or oil palm
biofuels it wasn't in growing food and
it certainly wasn't in growing food to
send back to China so we really we were
a lot of the interest in what the
Chinese were doing
crystallized during the last food
security that when global prices were
rising very sharply around 2008 and so
because there was a lot of investor
interest in in acquiring land because it
looked as though it was becoming more
valuable and then people worried about
food security and they thought that the
Chinese were getting quite worried about
food security so these things came
together and they just interpreted
investor interest from China as being
about food security and it's China in
virtually every African country or just
specific ones if you're talking about
China as an investor or China as a aid
partner they're just about everywhere
as an investor as some as where their
companies are seeking business they're
really everywhere even in places like
Somalia if you're talking about
diplomatically there are three countries
that still recognize Taiwan so there's
no Chinese government presence there but
in terms of Chinese companies bidding on
infrastructure projects they're really
interested in getting that business all
over the continent and how is Africa
responding to China's presence there are
they liking it are there issues
maryland's hard to summarize 54
countries but we do have some public
opinion data of that and so there are a
number of groups including the BBC and
afro barometer and the pew pew
charitable trust as a survey on public
opinion and what we can see from that is
that the opinion about the Chinese is it
varies country by country in some
countries it's quite positive others
it's less so South Africa for example
it's very negative and then we compare
this with the United States and what's
interesting is that on average the
public opinion is very similar and we're
more popular the u.s. is more popular
than the Chinese but in general on
average across a continent both China
and the United States are regarded
favorably and so I think with China the
main concern tends to be not so much
about the Chinese sending farmers there
because they aren't actually doing that
but it's about labor relations and this
is the thing I hear most whether it's
agriculture or mining or manufacturing
Africans are concerned about the
treatment that they get from Chinese
investors who have very different
cultural expectations so that's a real
blot on the Chinese in Africa it's a
problem it's a challenge and there are
others as well the environment it's
another issue I hear about but on the
other hand people are really positive
about the infrastructure that's being
built by Chinese companies so there are
good things and there are challenges
I'd say in this relationship and it's
growing very very rapidly right ok any
other message you'd like to tell us
about I think the last one that is
really interesting is this idea that
China is sending
a million farmers girl food in Africa
and I've seen this in several different
ways I've even seen it said to be a
hundred million that they want to
sandwich to Africa and so again there's
this idea of so many people and so much
land in Africa that's available and what
we found which is interesting is that
the small-scale farmers and there are
small-scale farmers from China growing
food and other crops in Africa almost
totally for local markets they're
supplying Chinese restaurants they're
supplying some African markets you can
now buy Chinese vegetables in in many
African markets things that you couldn't
buy before but these are not Chinese
farmers actually they are Chinese
entrepreneurs that have looked at
farming as a profitable niche investment
that they could make and so very few if
any of them actually come from a farming
background in China instead they're
businessman interesting all right let's
talk realities now Ryota are some of the
realities of China being in Africa other
than the ones that you've already
pointed out mmm well there are many
realities
I think trade is part of the reality and
this is something that in the u.s. we
look at with with some concern because
our export market in Africa's it's
complementary right now with China's
export market but it's it's relatively
small for example I think we're
exporting about 6070 billion or so maybe
even less so our total trade is probably
under a hundred million and so exports
would probably be less but Chinese
exports and Chinese trade with Africa's
right now about 220 billion dollars
annually so they're by far the largest
bilateral and bilateral trading partner
for the continent and they're exporting
a lot and one of the things they're
exporting is manufactured goods so in
many African countries another area of
tension is that Chinese goods coming in
and compete with local manufactured
goods so in South Africa that's very
much the case we also see this in Egypt
and in Nigeria in particular so people
that work in factories in those
countries are concerned
about having to compete with the Chinese
and this is going to be even tougher
because recently the Chinese devalued
their currency and so that makes their
experts even more competitive and harder
to compete with do you think the African
government will step in and shank
sanction some of them well this is
interesting Maryland because during the
1980s and 1990s African countries were
asked by the World Bank and the IMF to
liberalize their trade markets and so
they have they've opened their borders
to imports from outside and now they're
finding that it's the Chinese that are
supplying those imports that wasn't
quite what the intention was perhaps but
we have this idea that free trade is
always best at least that's the
Washington Consensus where where I come
from in Washington and that it becomes
very difficult to industrialize if you
have to open your borders to imports so
how do you actually move up the value
chain and get your factories to be able
to produce if they have no protection or
very little protection so I think what's
happening somewhat in Africa is that
they're starting to rethink this whole
idea of free trade and wonder how can
they protect their industries from China
and then try to move up the value chain
that way and I think that's a very
interesting conversation that's ongoing
ok and what do you think the trend will
be for China and Africa moving forward
any predictions I do have some
predictions I do think it's going to be
leveling off the intense interest that
we saw particularly from about 2004 to
about 2009 I looked at the trade figures
recently and trade was growing at over
40% annually during that period this is
a huge increase and then from 2009 to
2014 trade grew at under 15% per year so
that's a big settling down and so I
think that kind of suddenly down will be
the trend in the future we're not going
to see those huge increases that we saw
about 10 years ago and why do you think
it's settling down just because there's
more goods in the country at this point
people aren't buying them what do you
what do you think is the rationale for
that it will settle down for two reasons
one is that African economies
also growing more slowly and so that
means that they have less ability to
import things from China so that
consumption side will slow down and on
the side of the Chinese they their
economy is also slowing and so they have
less need for the commodities that
they've been importing from Africa so
that trade will slow down as well and
then when you have less need that's less
price pressure and so the prices of all
those commodities will slow which means
the total value of the trade will slow
and we already see this happening okay
and in what you conclude in your book I
conclude may be surprisingly given
everything I've said today but I do
think that Africa should feed China it's
not at present I don't see it happening
in the foreseeable future but the fact
that they have so much land that is not
being productively used the fact that so
many parts of the continent have not yet
really adopted commercial agriculture I
do think there are things they could
learn from the way the Chinese invited
in for an investment into their own
agricultural sector and there are a lot
of examples of that in my book but I
also saw in my research that in the past
some parts of Africa had exported quite
a bit for example Zimbabwe before they
had this disastrous land reform they
used to export to Asia to Indonesia
Malaysia Japan and even to China so they
were the breadbasket of southern Africa
and I think that could happen again
possibly it's it's a challenge to get
agricultural development going and to
commercialize it is a challenge because
right now in many parts of the continent
you have subsistence agriculture you
have basically regions where capitalism
has hardly entered and so people are
subs are producing for their own
families and maybe a little bit extra
for the market and the land is not being
used efficiently and yet these are
people with with very real needs very
poor people and taking their land away
which is what's happened everywhere else
in the world that this kind of
subsistence farming this is doesn't
exist in very many places anymore this
is a very painful transition so everyone
wants at least well-meaning people want
to make this to be less painful and
want to help these small farmers to move
up the value chain my own view on that
is that some areas this might work but
in a lot of parts of the continent it's
unrealistic the small farmers are not
going to be the future in many parts of
Africa they're going to move to the
cities they're going to look for jobs
there and they will have to
commercialize on a larger scale but this
is still very controversial and I don't
think it's been accepted by a lot of
Africa's partners as well as by a lot of
Africans themselves ok very interesting
thank you so much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your work it's
been a pleasure thank you for having me
for more information about professor
Brautigan and her research please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale